[Music]
um
so we're just going to do the interview
here and then go where and then go
right around the corner to the studio
then when you say what
right around the corner just five
minutes walking no we're gonna get in
the car
you know what else i think it's
interesting is that the current um
music that i have it sounds like hip
it sounds like pop and it sounds like
country
yeah so i've never heard an album like
that where you
you have all different genres why does
he call himself little nauseas do you
know
no so i think that's a good question for
him definitely a good question for him
because his name's montero
right and then this is his yearbook
in yearbooks yesterday
he wrote the essence of life is
statistically improbably
on a colossal scale that's what he's
saying that was his quote
[Music]
knock knock
can nobody tell me
nice to meet you i know i'm so glad to
meet you i'm so happy for your success
so so so hello team hi i'm so
so happy for you really you're living
like people's dreams
a little bit i'm running a little bit
there's somebody sitting at home right
now saying i wish i had that
seriously i wonder if you've had time to
even take it all in but we can talk
about it all
you want us to go sit down sure
you you booked this you made the magic
happen
it took a few months yeah so you came
here earlier set up this shot
back here nice yes average two to three
hours just depending on what it is
the anchor of the show so um
you know it's all high profile more time
we get the better
as you can see hopefully it looks good
looks good
soon it'll be right there
[Music]
[Music]
real quick why are we out here because
we're gonna take our horse a little town
road
so the all-time road was starring some
chickens chickens
all right david morgan okay cinco
[Music]
uh it actually is down the steps
fun of me i think alexis is trying to
look at other flights i don't think
we're going to make it
yeah there's another flight at 6 30.
you